[Music]
bridget's in midland texas hi bridget
how are you
hi guys thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up
um
so i was wondering if i should take out
a mortgage and buy a house or
um continue working and save up
and just pay pay cash for a house my
ultimate goal is to go to crna school
which is a three-year program
and
i am not able to work during that time
because it's a very rigid program
and
so here are my numbers
i'm single with no kids i'm 27 years old
i am an rn and i travel for work
i have an income of so far because my my
income varies
depending on the contract that i have
so right now
so far i have
137 000 so far
my emergency fund is is uh already done
it i have it there um i'm debt free i
have no student loans no car loan i just
have my rent plus my bills how much is
your rent
a thousand and one hundred and crna
schools how long two years
three years three years and what's it
cost a year
um i was looking it up and it said a
total of uh
one hundred thousand
a total
at one particular school
yeah this is in houston yeah yeah okay
so 100 000 in tuition and books or does
that include living
expenses uh with living expenses as well
really
you only need a hundred thousand dollars
and you make 137 and you're single
yeah and my savings is eighty four
thousand dollars i mean eighty four
yeah thousand dollars and you have 84
000 already saved
yes wow
okay so what's the deal go to school i
mean you work six more months and then
go to school what does the house have to
do with this
um
uh because i don't want to go to school
yet i'm still because i'm racing my
little brother and he's still in school
so i have to wait for him to get um to
go to college which should be in about
seven years so in the meantime i'm
taking care of him and
i just want to buy a house and you know
build equity and
with the money that i have i don't have
to get take out loans and
um because my ultimate goal is to sell
this house live in houston and not
having to pay rent just the bills and
with whatever money left i have just
paid you know bills and tuition and all
of that
so this is a 10-year journey you said
seven more years three let's stop
your little brother is
seven years old
no he's 12.
he's 12. so seven more years he'll be
gone you're saying okay right yeah
man you're amazing you took on the
raising of your little brother what
happened to your parents
um
there my dad is just not in the picture
and our mom passed away
about five years ago
you're amazing
okay so who takes care of your little
brother now he goes to school during the
day
and you have like after school you have
like after school care
uh no my sister has been helping me out
with him when i travel
and go on my contracts and then when i
come back i how long are you on a
contract
uh it depends so when kobet was at its
peak i was doing like eight week
contracts
where is your sister in midland as well
yes
we live together so that's why my my
rent is a little high because i rent a
three bedroom you know what does your
sister do for a living
um right now she just got separated from
her baby daddy and
so she's just helping with racing the
kids because she's got three kids on her
own
she's about to go to school full time
this upcoming fall and um
that's where we're at i know how old is
she
she's 23. so you're the mama this whole
bunch aren't you
um
you know what would work
since you're since you're committed to
this plan
load up the whole bunch and go to
houston now
you kick everybody yeah
and you know well within six months you
don't do it right now
uh your sister's not working
so she can land where you tell her to if
you're taking care of her too
and she's going to start school she can
start school in houston as easy as she
can in midland houston's where you can
get your crn n a
but um
if you can save up enough to take care
of you're saying that the hundred
thousand recover your living expenses
including your rent right
well my rent will be paid off i was
thinking you know what no you're not
gonna pay off the house and go to crno
you don't have the money
you only got a hundred thousand
you need a hundred thousand for school
that leaves zip for a house do you own
the house you're in
no i rent yeah i thought so
yeah i'm trying to keep you from having
to put your life on hold for the
responsibility that you took on for your
brother and your sister
and that's kind of why i'm thinking i'm
taking them all to houston sister can
take care of her kids and little brother
while you go to school
in return you help support them and take
care of them which is what you've done
and you could execute that next spring
next spring yeah i mean because you can
probably save another 50 grand by spring
can't you
oh yeah yeah that's what i would do and
then the house gets that way it's not a
seven-year plan
okay so
if you were this boy's mama
you would not put your life on hold as
his mama and you're playing mama now
you've taken over the care of him you
would go ahead and figure out a way to
go to school and you'd take him with you
and go to school and the only thing is
who's taking care of him now sister well
you're taking care of her so that's a
fair trade she can just load up and go
with you
i'm going to save another 50 grand or
more by next spring and then i'm going
to school and take them all with you
they don't really have a say in the
matter you're the one taking care of
everybody they're going to go where you
tell them to they're under your roof and
i would put the house on pause at that
point and let's get ready to buy a house
you need to go to school
because that's going to increase your
income as well which is only going to
help later on with the house purchase
and then when you finish school in three
years and your sister has finished
school in three years and she can get
out on her own become sustainable your
little brother will almost be there
and then we can start talking about
buying a house at that point
and i don't know what will happen in
your personal life during that period of
time either
uh hopefully your entire personal life
won't be on hold
you're an amazing young woman you have
taken on a tremendous responsibility
with a big heart thank you for doing
that yeah uh thank you for being that
kind of person that little boy
has a hero in his life and it's his
older sister
and so uh however i think there's a way
you can manipulate these facts
tactically to not have to put your life
on hold for seven years
i think i think we just you know we do
what we all do with our kids we drag
them through the adventure
they go along for the adventure that's
how the kiddo thing works
and um
yeah i think i would wow what an
interesting
situation and what a beautiful woman man
i mean it's impressive making bank she's
working her tail off taking care of the
family everybody can depend on her
because she's that kind of gal way to go
bridgette this is the ramsay show